[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Wilbur
and Orville Wright.
The first men in the
history of the world
to pilot a heavier
than air craft
and sustain flight
under power and control.
MINDELL: The Wright
brothers were
great pioneers in the
way they approached
the problem of flight.
NARRATOR: The speed
about 40 miles an hour,
altitude, as you see,
about 75 to a 100 feet.
MINDELL: There are a lot of
different ideas about what
an airplane should look like
and what the wings should
look like, but there's not
all that much data out there.
They combined empirical
studies in a wind tunnel
with the actual desire
to build an airplane
and learn how to fly it.
MIT brings that combination
to the next level,
to really build the tools, build
the instruments, take the data,
compare it to the
physical principles,
and understand
what you're doing.
ROY: What we have done is
largely focused on the software
challenges.
What are the algorithms that
allow different kinds of sensor
information to be brought
together and fused
into consistent estimate
of where the vehicle is
and what's around it?
How do you plan trajectories
through the environment that
are safe, that allow the
vehicle to move quickly,
and without collision?
How do you incorporate
information
about what's in the world?
How do you incorporate
sensor information
that tells you what's changing?
And how should the vehicle
construct new plans
in order to react to
that new information?
Small air vehicles
are just going
to become part of our
everyday existence.
They're going to be a new source
of information about the world
and they're going to be a new
way to move things around.
And we're just going to take it
for granted 100 years from now.
MINDELL: Aeronautical
engineering
is a funny kind of
engineering because it's
a really kind of systems
discipline from the beginning.
ROY: There is the
system's problem
of how do you integrate
these vehicles safely?
How do you integrate
these vehicles reliably?
How do they do all
the things they
need to do without getting
in each other's way?
I mean, that's a
huge research problem
that's going to take
many years to solve.
And I think there's
an opportunity for us
as a department to really
be part of the solution.
MINDELL: Airplanes are the glue
that knit the global system
together, but the focus is on
making them more efficient,
on making the system more
efficient, making it more
environmentally friendly.
URANGA: The idea was
design an airplane that
could save 70% fuel.
If you think about a fuselage,
it's one single bubble.
And this one is two bubbles.
So the fuselage is wider.
It lifts more.
Even the Wright brothers
had a wind tunnel
because we want to
know what's happening.
Is this airplane
actually flying?
Is it going to lift off?
Is it not?
And then you want to be
able to change things
in a controlled environment.
All right, turn it on.
So I'm going to go first
gear and then second gear.
The tunnel is blowing 100
miles per hour on the model.
We're actually having a
big computational effort.
And they're actually simulating
exactly the conditions
we're running in the tunnel.
So you can validate things
for the computations
and then the computations can
do much more than you could do,
because your tunnel's
limited in speed or what not.
But their computations isn't.
So, I think experiments,
wind tunnels, computations,
you can make an
airplane out of that.
STUDENT 1: Start at zero.
Idle.
Hold for two minutes.
Get the okay.
Increase power to 14,500.
MINDELL: MIT's model for
a research university
has always been that the best
way to educate students is get
them involved in the research.
URANGA: Okay,
tunnel speed is off.
Shutting down the tunnel.
I tell you, I have
a bet with a friend
that this thing is going to
fly in the next 20 years.
OKELLO: Each person
in this department
has some kind of drive within
them, some kind of problem
that they want to solve.
LOHMEYER: The SPHERES project is
one of the really cool projects
in space systems lab.
They actually have
satellites inside the ISS
that they can control and
send different algorithms
to to improve the way that we
design satellites and operate
with the astronauts.
ASTRONAUT: Like Craig and
Katie, I studied science, math,
and engineering at
MIT and it's taken me
on a wonderful path of
discovery and adventure.
STUDENT 2: We have
two different motors
and the way the
hitch is controlled
is by a servo that can tilt
the entire kind of axis.
PERAIRE: The main strength of
the department are its people.
Its faculty, its students,
its industrial partners,
its alumni.
It's really the
community we have been
fortunate to be able to create.
STUDENT 3: You're going
to go a lot faster
if you go straight, as opposed
to if you're zig-zagging.
So control is really what makes
or breaks this competition.
ROY: The best part
of each and every day
that I have here is
meeting with my students,
working through
research problems.
We are incredibly
fortunate at MIT
to have the best
students in the world.
OKELLO: It's the people
around you that definitely
keep you going and that's
one of the main things
I love about this department.
PERAIRE: It's really very
humbling to see what people
before us have done.
NARRATOR: MIT is best known for
the scientists and engineers
who have studied there.
PERAIRE: It started
with a vision,
but then we have
been tremendously
fortunate to attract the people
we've been able to attract.
Whether it is Hunsaker,
Dolittle, Draper.
Tremendous individuals
who've made major advances.
ROY: This kind of basic research
into control and estimation,
sensing, et cetera, has been
a part of our department's
history for many, many years.
The instrumentation lab at
Draper, the Apollo missions,
were all things that came
out of this department,
and it's great to be
continuing that tradition.
PERAIRE: We've been
fortunate to graduate
a large number of
astronauts, whether it
is Apollo or the space shuttle.
It's something that happens.
We do not have a
deliberate attempt
to really attract
astronauts, per se.
I think it's a byproduct of the
way we do research and the way
we do our work.
MINDELL: Still to this
day, if young people say,
what do I have to do
to become an astronaut?
Go get a PhD at MIT is a pretty
common answer they'll hear.
STUDENT 4: This length is
actually five millimeters.
URANGA: People in this
department at MIT in AeroAstro,
in particular, they're very
excited about what they do.
NEWMAN: Okay.
URANGA: Who gets
to go to the moon?
Who gets to launch
a rocket, right?
Who gets to design
the next airplane?
And I think that's what
you have to do in life,
you have to do what you like.
People do it because
it was their dream.
NEWMAN: So we're trying to
enable astronaut performance
on the moon or Mars,
get back to the planets.
And it's kind of extreme.
We're really going to be
going up very steep terrain,
we're going to be going
down, looking at craters.
How can we design space suits
and life support systems
to enable that exploration?
The current
traditional space suits
are big gas
pressurized balloons.
They're very immobile,
they're very heavy.
We kind of flip that and say
no, no we want a 20 kilo.
In order of magnitude
reduction in mass, for sure.
As well as maximizing
the mobility.
If I'm going to design a suit
that applies pressure directly
over your skin, essentially I'd
like it to be a second skin.
That's the real
research question,
how can I make a second skin?
We need to apply a
third of an atmosphere,
so our design goal
is 30 kilopascals.
That's the same pressurization
of the gas pressurized suits,
so we're trying to match
the current system.
But now get rid of the gas,
get rid of the balloon,
put the pressure
directly on the skin.
And we think this patterning
is really important.
I like to describe it lots
of times as a smart zipper.
So, yeah.
You don on this, you put
it on, it's comfortable,
but maybe a little bit loose.
If you apply it in the
active materials and it
shrinks it up to get to
our desired pressure state.
They generate actually a lot of
force when they're activated.
This is just
stainless steel wire,
but now imagine
this was the shape
memory alloys that we
just played around with.
So, if I open this
up, it's going
to give you a couple extra
centimeters here, to don.
You know, to jump into, right?
Rather than me doing
it mechanically,
the shape memory alloy, when
is activated under the voltage
or the heat, it cinches it up.
MINDELL: Space is not quite
the technological frontier
it was in the '50s where it
was a bit of a wild west.
The challenges that
we're left with in space
are really, very hard
challenges and they may not
be solved by new inventions.
They may be solved by
kind of some end runs
around some of the
difficult problems.
MILLER: I think in 60 years,
we'll have been on Mars.
Becoming a multi-planet
species, getting out
of the cradle of
Earth, permanently.
OKELLO: Soon we may
overpopulate the Earth.
We may actually need
to look outward.
MILLER: We're going
to be able to point up
at skies in our
local neighborhood
and say, there are water
worlds there, there, and there.
Is there intelligent
life on them?
How do we communicate with them?
And how are we
going to get there?
BUTCHIBABU: We're going to have
a lot of intelligent systems
in the future.
And more automation and
more intelligent automation.
OKELLO: Archeology is like
you know, discovering more
about our past and understanding
of where we've been.
And I kind of see AeroAstros
like understanding
of where we can go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]